Básicamente, hay un evento demográfico importantísimo llevándose a cabo.
Y puede ser que al pasar del 50 por ciento de población urbana
quizás lleguemos a un punto de inflexión económico. El mundo actual es un mapa de conectividad.
París, Londres y Nueva York solían ser las ciudades más grandes.
Presenciamos el fin del auge del Oeste. Eso terminó.
Las cantidades totales son abrumadoras.
¿Qué está sucediendo? Que los pueblos del mundo se están vaciando.
La pregunta es: ¿Por qué?
Y esta es la verdad sin barniz: "y el aire de la ciudad te hará libre"
decían en la Alemania del Renacimiento. Algunas personas van a lugares
como Shanghai pero casi todas van a asentamientos irregulares... donde norma la estética.
Y estas no son exactamente personas oprimidas por la pobreza.
Son personas que intentan salir de la pobreza tan rápido como pueden.
Son los constructores y, en gran medida, los diseñadores dominantes.
Tienen infraestructura hecha en casa y una vida urbana vibrante.
Un sexto del PNB de la India sale de Mumbai.
Siempre están mejorándose y, en algunos casos, el gobierno los está ayudando.
La educación es lo más importante que sucede en las ciudades.
¿Qué sucede en las calles de Mumbai?
Al Gore lo sabe. Básicamente de todo. (ECONOMIA INFORMAL)
No hay desempleo en los asentamientos. Todos trabajan.
Un sexto de la humanidad está ahí. Pronto serán más.
Aquí viene la primera sorpresa.
Las ciudades desactivaron la bomba poblacional.
Y aquí viene la segunda sorpresa. (LAS CIUDADES CREAN RIQUEZA).
Esas son las noticias de acá abajo. Pongámoslo en perspectiva.
Las estrellas han brillado sobre la vida en la tierra por miles de millones de años.
Ahora nosotros estamos brillándoles de vuelta.
Gracias.